MOLLY:  AFTER MONTHS OF TESTING
ON COVID-19 PATIENTS, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION SAYS IT’S
ENDING TRIALS OF ANTI-MALARIA
DRUG, HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, WHICH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOUTED AND TOOK
HIMSELF AS WELL.
THE UN AGENCY ALSO ENDING
COVID-19 TRIALS OF A COMBO OF
HIV DRUGS SAYING THEY AND
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE PRODUCED,
QUOTE, LITTLE OR NO REDUCTION IN
THE MORTALITY OF HOSPITALIZED
COVID-19 PATIENTS WHEN COMPARED
TO STANDARD CARE.
JOINING US NOW, FAMILY AND
EMERGENCY MEDICINE DOCTOR, JANET
NESHEIWAT, A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
MOLLY:  TALKING ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, IT ALWAYS
SEEMS LIKE THERE’S THIS AURA OF
POLITICS AROUND IT BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF ACKNOWLEDGED
HE TOOK A TWO WEEK COURSE, THE
DOCTOR SAYING THERE WAS NO HARM
THAT CAME OF THAT.
IT PROVED IT WAS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL, THE PRESIDENT
CRITICIZED POSSIBLY PUTTING
THOSE WHO MIGHT TAKE THE DRUG IN
DANGER.
NOW THE LATEST FROM THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THEIR RESULTS?
>> YES.
SO INITIALLY, MOLLY, THIS IS A
NEW VIRUS AND WE WERE DESPERATE
TO TRY ANYTHING THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY SAVE LIVES AND WE
HAD INITIAL ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWED THAT THIS DRUG MAY
HAVE BEEN THERAPEUTIC AND MAY
HAVE HELPED TO SAVE LIVES IN
THOSE WHO WERE SEVERELY ILL AND
HOSPITALIZED, ON VENTILATORS.
SO WHAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DID, THEY HALTED
WHAT’S CALLED THE SOLIDARITY
TRIAL.
THIS IS A TRIAL THAT INCLUDED
THREE DIFFERENT MEDICATIONS, NOT
JUST HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE ALONE.
IT INCLUDED TWO HIV MEDICINES,
PLUS HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, AND
WHAT IT SHOWED WAS THERE WAS NO
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
MORTALITY IN THOSE WHO ARE
HOSPITALIZED, THOSE WHO ARE
REALLY ILL.
IT DID NOT SHOW ANY INCREASED
MORTALITY, MEANING THIS TRIAL,
THESE MEDICATIONS DID NOT CAUSE
HARM TO THE PATIENTS WHO WERE
HOSPITALIZED AND IT DOES NOT
AFFECT THE POTENTIAL STUDY AND
USE IN THE PREVENTATIVE USE OF
THIS MEDICATION.
SO THAT’S REALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID,
THERE’S SO MANY STUDIES OUT
THERE, SOME THAT SHOW THAT IT’S
HELPFUL, SOME THAT SHOW THAT
IT’S HARMFUL.
THE MOST RECENT STUDY THAT CAME
OUT PUBLISHED IN THE JOURNAL OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AT THE
HOSPITAL, HENRY FORD IN
MICHIGAN, SHOWED THAT ABOUT 13%
OF 2400 PATIENTS HAD A MORTALITY
REDUCTION IF THEY WERE PUT ON
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE VERSUS 26%
MORTALITY IN THOSE WHO WERE NOT
ON IT.
SO IT’S SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO
TALK TO YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT.
AGAIN, THERE’S STILL LOTS MORE
STUDIES THAT NEED TO BE
CONDUCTED.
BUT FORTUNATELY WE HAVE OTHER
MEDICATIONS AND OTHER
THERAPEUTICS EVOLVING SUCH AS
REMDESIVIR, STEROIDS, AND
CONVALESCENT PLASMA IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS WELL AS THE VACCINE
THAT’S UNDER DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW AND THEN MONO MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF IN DEVELOPMENT
IN THE PIPELINE.
THIS IS ANOTHER STUDY TO SHOW
THAT IT MIGHT WORK AND WE HAVE
ALL THESE OTHER STUDIES THAT
SHOW THAT IT MAY NOT.
SO WE HAVE TO WEIGH THOSE IN.
MOLLY:  I WAS READING THAT AS
WELL, THE TEAM AT HENRY FORD
HEALTH SYSTEMS OUT OF MICHIGAN,
THAT STUDY, 2,541 HOSPITALIZED
PATIENTS.
THE GOAL IN ALL OF THIS IS TO
NOT BECOME HOSPITALIZED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF STATES, ARIZONA,
FLORIDA, TEXAS, ALL SEEING
ENORMOUS SPIKES IN NUMBERS,
TEXAS SEEING SOME RECORD
RECORD-BREAKING CASES, FLORIDA
ALSO REPORTING RECORD-BREAKS
CASES.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS ARE BASICALLY
PLEADING WITH THE PUBLIC TO WEAR
MASKS.
BUT IS THAT ENOUGH OR DOES THERE
NEED TO BE MORE OF AN EFFORT TO
SELF-ISOLATE?
HOW DO WE TURN BACK THIS TIDE
THAT IS SO FRIGHTENING THERE IN
THE SUN BELT?
>> YEAH, SO IT’S MULTIFACTORIAL.
IT’S A COMBINATION OF FACIAL
COVERING, PHYSICAL DISTANCING,
KEEPING HANDS WASHED AND
CLEANED, AVOIDING LARGE CROWDS.
THE SPREAD IN THE VIRUS IS
PROPAGATED IN FLORIDA BECAUSE OF
THE OPENING OF BARS AND
RESTAURANTS AND THE LACK OF
COMPLIANCE.
GOVERNORS ARE TAKING ACTION,
SCALING BACK, SHUTTING DOWN BARS
AND RESTAURANTS TEMPORARILY.
THEY SHUT DOWN THE BEACHES TO
TRY TO MITIGATE THE TRANSMISSION
OF THE VIRUS.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, THERE’S A
POTENTIAL MUTATION IN THE VIRUS
WHICH MAKES IT UP TO 10 TIMES
MORE TRANS MISS I’LL.
PERHAPS -- TRANSMISSABLE,
PERHAPS THE STATES ARE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL
MUTATION AS WELL, NOT JUST THE
LACK OF COMPLIANCE.
WE NEED TO GET ON TARGET AND
MAKE SURE WE ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE, COVER YOUR FACE
BECAUSE THAT’S HOW THIS VIRUS
SPREADS FROM ONE PERSON TO
ANOTHER BY AEROSOLIZING THE
VIRUS.
WE HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE.
WE HAVE TO ADHERE TO IT.
MOLLY:  DR. NESHEIWAT THANK YOU